[MUSIC PLAYING]
I definitely think the human
journey is characterized
by a desire to expand
what we can see.
We've had this uncanny
ability to engineer solutions
for our perceptual limitations.
So we couldn't see in
the microwave spectrum,
other modalities within the
electromagnetic spectrum.
And we create these
tools-- radar and scanners
and so on and so forth.
These instruments that
allow us to all of a sudden
perceive other dimensions beyond
what our senses can usually
detect.
We've also could only
experience a moment
before it's gone, right?
And with tools like the camera,
the digital lens, the iris,
all of a sudden we are extending
the eye to freeze frame,
to hold in stasis the
passing moment, effectively
immortalizing the most
elusive thing we know,
which is the now.
That's why I love
cameras like this one.